[Music]
Nathan is on Instagram why do you think
all debt is bad isn't some debt okay
like a house or student loans Nathan
when you ask a question that is actually
a statement that's called a passive
aggression aggressive question so you
weren't really asking a question you
were just saying you think all debt is
not bad and I'm wrong that's the truth
of your statement now so you and I will
now argue are you ready
it's fun so here's the thing is it's not
as necessarily what Dave Ramsey thinks I
happen to be the aggregator of the
information meaning I've gathered the
information over thirty years of walking
with people with millionaires and
billionaires and broke people so I have
a lot of data a whole lot more than your
brother-in-law with his opinion or the
idiot you were playing golf with
yesterday and his opinion our data says
that the shortest direction the shortest
distance between you and wealth is
having no debt our data comes from
researching millionaires in detail
formal research projects having had five
million families go through Financial
Peace University having answered 15
hours of questions on this show for
coming up on 30 years now having read
the Bible and what it says about money
and there's no time in there that it
says student loans are a good idea or a
mortgage is a good idea so get out of
that if you hate it and I'm wrong you
can go back in back but it's the
shortest distance to wealth and to you
being more generous that's why I hate
that this is the Dave Ramsey show